Being a teenager means a wonderful time of exploring, learning, and building friendships, but also
Is the time of rapid changes, ups and downs when things are difficult
So, what gets into our minds and bodies that makes us feel this way?
Why is it difficult to be a teenager?
They have always told us that the most important years of mind development are between 0-5 years
Although recent studies have shown that adolescence is just as important.
During childhood, our minds continue to grow, and continue to produce gray matter until it reaches maximum
Measurement, as girls reach 12 years of age and males at the age of 14 years
The brain works more efficiently by eliminating the gray matter that has not been used
And at the same time produce myelin-fatty tissue that isolates brain pathways
The stage of puberty begins from the hypothalamus (one of the parts of the brain's core), where the globular hormone is produced, stimulating
The pituitary gland releases the hormones testosterone, estrogen and progesterone. These hormones
Activates ovaries and testicles, but also causes emotionally rich experiences
Whether it made you yawn or drive 180 km / h on the highway
Your response to emotionally charged images or sounds will make you tougher
Listening to the One Direction band may give rise to emotional shifts.
The area responsible for advance planning and risk assessment is still immature in adolescents
This is why adolescents are involved in risky behaviors
Such as illegal relationships, drinking, and driving. Surprising that in the simulation driving experience,
The adults and teenagers took the same recklessness when they were alone; but when they were surrounded
With fans or friends, adolescents took higher risks while adults were not affected.
What is the purpose of this action? Accept its peers.
In a study where adolescents were asked to classify music, their choice was influenced by their knowledge or ignorance of what their peers chose.
Unlike children and adults, you feel like a teenager
Socially isolated creates a strong sense of this vanity with our vitality
Adolescents may make their friends a priority on their families.
As social reasons, getting out of the family safety creates a society that is genetically disorganized, downplayed
Proportion of marriage. In fact, adolescents have social capabilities
And a better separation of facial expressions compared to all other ages, making adolescents
Greater awareness of the joy of friends, grief, pressure.
In talking about pressure, the hormone is produced at the time of pressure to help relieve
Stress on brain cells in children and adults has an adverse effect on adolescents
Causing an increase in tension. Coupled with a change in the rhythmic rhythms of the clock that make their bodice stay flat
For another 3-4 hours, I was surprised that some people describe teenagers
With moody people
On the other hand, teenagers are considered to be very healthy physically. The immune system is very effective
Adolescents have high adaptation to temperature changes and greater cancer immunity. But
Regardless of physical fitness, records show a 200 to 300% increase in mortality rates after childhood
Due to car accidents, homicides, and suicide.
Scientists believe that
The many changes in white matter, gray, and brain connections are blamed
Which may raise the risk of mistakes during adolescence.
But with large numbers of network connections, high flexibility, the brain of the teenager
Come to learn faster and remember content quickly. In contrast to the old-fashioned brains of his school
Adolescents can respond faster to their environment and leapfrog steps
In communication and social integration. Not to mention being passionate, it gives valuable value.
Sometimes risking is needed to make a difference in your life and the lives of others.
Being a teenager may be difficult, but it can be amazing.
If you want to know what teenagers are the supernatural fans and become obsessed
With their favorite teams or offers, explore the latest AsapTHOUGHT admirably
Links in the description box! I have participated in more weekly scientific sections.